[Music]
it was a strong year for new releases
but a number of expansions for existing
games wowed us as well an expansion to
The Witcher 3 Wild Hunt appears on our
list for a second straight year as CD
Projekt RED followed up last year's
excellent hearts of stone expansion with
another hit blood and wine debuting in
May the add-on transported players to
the vibrant and colorful world of
Toussaint's quests and activities
abounded while new features like a
mutation system gave players the ability
to add passive bonuses and other skill
facts this was a welcome feature as it
added a new flavor to combat and the way
you can interact with the world with The
Witcher 3 being the final Witcher game
to star garel and this being its last
expansion the monster hunter goes out in
style with blood and wine in the PC
space blizzards genre-defining MMO World
of Warcraft welcomed its six expansion
in August Legion was praised by GameSpot
and others for its story that had
genuine stakes and consequences while
the new demon hunter class shakes things
up by being more action-oriented than
others the new zones are some of the
most expansive and diverse ever seen in
the game overall Blizzard proves all
over again with Legion that it knows how
to bring players back with an epic
expansion dying light the following
landed in February evolving the game's
core formula with new mechanics and
features and the standout one being the
dirt buggy running around on foot is
fine but being able to cover more ground
in a car dials up the moment-to-moment
excitement significantly whereas the
base game is focused on parkour ready
environments the following takes place
upside of her on to a new vehicle
friendly world as you progress through
the DLC you pick up new upgrades for
your buggy including the likes of
flamethrowers and deployable mines the
expansion overall is a beefy one
including a main story side missions and
even new skill based challenges we won't
spoil it here but the ending had a
pretty cool story twist and we did
coming blizzards hearthstone heroes of
Warcraft had one of the best add-ons in
2016 in whispers of the old gods
released in May whispers of the old gods
mixed things up with a hundred and
thirty-four new cards including those
for the famous Warcraft characters
C'thun ye'arj yogg-saron and nazar the
expansion also changed up the popular
collectible card games formula with a
new standard and wild mode in standard
mode you can play with a deck that pulls
from a pool of cards released in the
current and previous calendar year wild
mode on the other hand is a format where
anything can happen this expansion felt
fresh with new features and took steps
to make the free-to-play game more
accessible for newcomers another shining
example of expansion content this year
came in the form of strategy game XCOM
two's Shen's last gift add on the
expansion lets you bring sentient robots
called sparks in the battle the Robo
creatures have more health and firepower
than a standard human soldier and
because they can't take cover you'll
need to adjust your strategy like human
characters the sparks also have to
progression paths to move through giving
you a reason to stick with the
characters over the long haul there's
also an excellent news story mission to
take on where you play as engineer Lily
Shen Shen's last gift is a present
you'll be happy to open
[Music]